[Music]
we dismiss the supernatural as the stuff
of fairy tale and fantasy yet Vic and
Stein argued that science is mistaken in
making it look as if everything can be
said is our continuing interest in the
supernatural and paranormal a sign of an
underlying truth about the limits of
human understanding or are we correct
dismiss them as the illusory fantasies
of a popular culture now our three
speakers are Lawrence Scott who is an
award-winning writer and cultural
commentator Julian Virginie is a writer
journalist and co-founder of the
Philosopher's Magazine now Deborah levy
is an award-winning novelist and
playwright her novels include hot milk
and swimming home and two works most
recently of memoir including the cost of
living I think that was the latest we've
got pictures we've got arguments and
then we'll hand over to you for
questions so the the opening question
and I'm coming to you Julian first is do
supernatural beliefs reflect the truth
about the limits of human understanding
well they reflect something about the
limits of understanding I think the
point is you people are myself who I in
crude terms are like you know naturalist
atheist materialists often sort of
accused of having a sort of too narrow
imagination you know there are more
things in heaven and earth that are
dreamt of in our philosophy although
they I think there are certain people
who belong to that broad camp who are
absurdly reductive and think that if
there isn't an a scientific equation for
which then it isn't really real I think
most people don't succumb to that
stereotype and I think the reason is
that I think if you properly if you
properly accept the limits of reason as
you surely must that doesn't mean that
you only speak of that which can be a
scientific leave a ledee to yes means
you're very cautious about what you are
sent to which lacks evidence and so
forth and so what I find kind of ironic
really is a lot of the people who
you advocate things like the the
supernatural and so forth
and not really as they say are what do
you know human reason is so limited and
that's why you have to embrace all these
things which are beyond our
understanding well no actually if these
if you understand is limited then
confine yourself to those limits and
those will leap off into wild
speculations about what might be but one
thing I think is worth remembering about
this though is that when we talk about
the supernatural
we tend just got confused to rather
separate things there's a supernatural
understood as that which goes beyond the
natural world
another dimensions supernatural in the
sort of literal etymological sense but
actually there's a lot of things which
are just supernatural more in the sense
of Superman you know just so they're
they're kind of they're natural but
they're incredible so if you people who
believe in telepathy for example these
days they don't tend to think that slip
of these supernatural they think there's
some kind of mysterious process which
one day science will understand but it's
beyond us and I think that is the sort
of space which makes belief in a lot of
things people like myself dismiss is
just superstition or groundless possible
because human knowledge is limited
people can always say our harbour
there's all this other staff which we
just don't understand yet and I'm not
saying it's supernatural I'm saying that
we just haven't caught up with it yet
but it's just empty speculation most of
the time and I'm gonna move over to you
Laurence next do you supernatural
beliefs reflected truth about limits of
human understanding yeah I think the
word limits here is they're really sort
of the key one because to me human
interest cultural interest in the
supernatural it always has to do with
board is in some sense of the
supernatural for me is a threshold space
between what can be sort of empirically
verified and something which is so
deeply beyond our Ken that there's no
point and even thinking but it's
literally unthinkable and so this idea
of limit really is dramatized nicely in
the case of the Cottingley fairies which
had its centenary last year is a story
of two girls in Yorkshire in 1917 and
using very rudimentary techniques they
tricked sort of many people including
Arthur Conan Doyle that the fairies they
drawn and porn hatpins and then taking
pictures of themselves with at the
bottom of the garden were actually
moving and there was a hole it became a
very famous hoax at the time and one of
the reasons people speculate that Doyle
was so fascinated with this was that he
had a dog in the race in terms of the
supernatural meaning that he'd lost a
son in the war and he had a huge vested
interest in being able to communicate
with the other side but what's really
most interesting about this is how the
two girls grew up into women and
responded to it in old age and I read
the interview that Elsie Wright one of
the girls gave in the in 1985 and there
were a couple of things that she said
she said that the ultimately the
pictures were photographs of my and my
cousins imagination and I thought that
was a lovely way of hedging it it was
that was the ontological question are
fairies real or not didn't even apply to
them you know it was it was the wrong
sort of questioning and she said she was
sort of pressed well did you fake it did
you fake it and she said I'd like to
leave that open if you don't mind the
question I asked one more time and she
said let's close it with that and I love
that - it almost let that cup lift at
the end of leave it closing on an
opening and that's sort of the threshold
space that I think the supernatural in
our imaginative lives always occupies if
you look at fairy law it's always you
know the fairies will come on solstice
days or days where times of Twilight
where the our world in their world the
borders between the thinning and I think
what's most attractive to us and that's
what I'd like to sort of put forward
today is the way in which the
supernatural is always a confounding of
categories it's an either nor space the
Gothic literature a tradition in the
18th century was all abouts of the idea
of the ghost who is there or not there
or the werewolf who is neither beast nor
human and I think this huge imaginative
productive space that can come from
these sort of borderline border
phenomena and there's obviously
something we get out of it let's believe
in fairies do supernatural beliefs
reflective truth about the limits of
human understanding Deborah well I think
the supernatural expands
a truth on the limits of human
understanding we are all haunted by
whatever mum dad him they and the most
famous ghost story one of the most
famous ghost stories in the world is
written by Karl Marx Communist Manifesto
there is a specter haunting Europe
Derrida picks up on this in his book in
1993 arguing that Marx himself haunts
Europe from his grave forever so because
I because my attention is on language
and I don't just mean literary language
of course the supernatural is going to
expand some of the ways I think about
and write about the world the fact that
so many people believe that the
supernatural is a power that organizes
and animates the material universe has
to be interesting to me
however there's that there's that quote
from Raymond Carver he said if you ever
writing a new stack and you know in
you've got no plot bringing a man with a
gun and so there's another part of me
you know if I was writing out if if I
was commissioned to write in higher
honor I'd be really interesting to write
it but in my own work if I was going to
bring in the supernatural quite
literally I think it would be a bit like
bringing in a man with a gun on the
other hand you'll be familiar with that
phrase he's so straight he's a little
bit gay and we can I'd like to flip that
for this debate and say we can be so
rational we're just a little bit mad
[Music]
so my angle on the supernatural is that
it's an avatar with which to explore
human longings and regrets and desires
and anxieties and the art that I enjoy
so lien Laura Carrington and and and and
and a lot of surrealist art opens its
doors to flirt if you like and use the
the occult fantasies illusion
hallucinations and subliminal vistas and
then there are my sisters the witches
who were burnt for exposing the
patriarchy sphere of female potency and
sexuality so I would like to bring them
in and finally on telepathy Freud Freud
actually did believe in telepathy but he
thought it was going to sink his career
for modder bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute of arts and ideas her III
TV
you